prime minister's questions is famed as a
political Bear Pit
and never more so than when the
opposition tastes the blood of a deeply
wounded leader
this trusses botched mini budget has
left her twisting amidst the wreckage of
her unfunded tax cuts the UK's economy
and her political Future Ready with a
tally of everything she's been forced to
throw overboard was labor leader Kia
stammer I've got the list here 45p tax
cut gone corporation tax cut gone 20p
tax cut gone two-year energy freeze gone
tax-free shopping gone economic
credibility gone
and her supposed best friend the formula
Chancellor he's gone as well they're all
gone so why is she still here
[Applause]
I am a fighter and not a quetter
the problem is many of her own MPS might
secretly be wishing she was a bit more
of a quitter it would save them the
headache of ousting their second prime
minister in less than a year polls are
screaming at the conservative party that
they and Liz trust are profoundly
unpopular but Tory MPS haven't worked
out yet what to do about it I think it's
absolutely clear that Liz trust is not
going to lead the desert party into the
next gen election uh the question is how
soon the end comes and frankly it would
have already happened if the
Conservative Party come up with a
mechanism to make sure they could
replace it with somebody who is
palatable to the MPS
um and somebody who could unite all
sides of the party they've not been able
to do that so she's still there
out in the real world people are
absorbing the latest gloomy inflation
figures 10.1 percent in the year to
September and the sharpest rise in food
prices in 40 years
the Halloween decorations are up in this
London Cafe but the real horror is what
it costs just to keep running and the
past few months the prices of um
pastries we order on a daily basis
they've gone up by 30 prices of the milk
is gonna the prices of them water
electric we don't have gas but
everything everything to run a shark is
gonna
profits are down the business is
suffering does Ellie mind who's the
Prime Minister anyone who can do that
and are they doing the job
it's a view much of the British public
agrees with but as the government
doesn't have to call an election till
January 2025 it's a view the British
public will have to wait to express in a
voting booth Rory challenge out of zero